so you're on the the king and the sting
podcast
yeah with brendan shav and theovan right
so those two did you just because i feel
like the comedy store is like where
everybody kind of meets up is that how
you met them
as well or you know i met theo in
brendan back in 2016 actually yeah
in arizona and arizona theo wasn't even
like
they weren't even like where they're at
right now oh of course not yeah
yeah 2016 [ __ ] no yeah no not at all
yeah
so like yeah we were just you know uh
just from
you know i would hang out at the the the
comment like the tempi improv were stand
up live
all the time just because like i was
tight with all the staff there and
you know they would just let me come
kick it you know no uh
no problems and uh you know and then i
would just you know
those dudes would just come up just
start talking to me because like i said
i
i don't know what it is about me sitting
in a corner by myself
or something like that but people just
like hey man what you up to
you know type type deal like which is
what happens a lot
and then uh sometimes it's usually
through like a mutual friend but
you know yeah i met both of them you
know 2016 and all of a sudden like
did you guys like stay in contact that
whole time yeah or like oh that's
definitely yeah cause they were like yo
man take my number down like
you know you're real cool [ __ ] like that
blah blah like
it's funny because i feel like brendan
shop is the kind of guy you wouldn't
hang out with in high school
oh hell no hell no we say that we say
that [ __ ] all the time
like bro you guys would yo you just
roasted him the other day when he was
talking about nickelback
oh you remember that yeah i was like yo
yo this guy's shop is not a music head
whatsoever
and you're like you're like yeah you
would [ __ ] listen to nickels yeah i
was like yeah you wouldn't
make makes sense and he's he's so yeah
and he tries to make fun of me about
like you know he probably loves drake
too
yeah he does he does yeah he does
because he uh
he got a picture with drake of course he
does and he was like
i was like uh i was like what's he like
he was like man i was so excited but
anyways yeah so he
like you know i like punk yeah he thinks
like
metallica's punk rock no he thinks i
like he's a
he thinks i'm a big green day fan and
i'm like that's not
yeah that sounds i was like that's not
what i listen to but he doesn't know
that
right right he's like that he's like
that that jock in high school that
like make fun of you they were like oh
well your mom
and you're like oh okay cool yeah you're
funny bro yeah
he's like it's like because i i think
i follow i watch the podcast i thought
yeah i watched the the
the one with him and brian callan yeah
and uh yeah no he's definitely that guy
though
yeah it's hilarious but he like
literally
hands down is one of the nicest people
yeah i'm a fan of generous like
bro like you know during the quarantine
i was like i ain't had no gym membership
right right he brought me like these
expensive ass jump ropes which i didn't
know jump ropes could get expensive
right like i'll just go get some from
marshalls
yeah but he brought me like these
weighted ones they got a
app you got to download with yeah and
then
he got he gave me a kettlebell all this
[ __ ] anytime any fitness [ __ ] i would
just go to the middle of ross or
marshalls you know i got that little
area
oh yeah that ran reloading electronics
and weights is there marshalls out here
yeah at least in burbank there was one
yeah oh i didn't see it in hollywood so
he bought you some some stuff
yeah like he's just cool like that he'll
you know he'll take me on the road with
him too and then
like you know them bringing me on the
as a you know permanent uh person on the
king and the sting
has been like you know like i don't know
like all of a sudden
my following and all this [ __ ] people
just like [ __ ] with me heavy and like i
didn't realize
like what's so funny is i used to get
made fun of a lot about like the music i
would listen to
like being the black kid that listens to
it and literally
now like so many like a lot of the dm's
i get
is people asking me about music or want
to talk music with me
it's like insane like so many people
follow me because they see all the band
t-shirts i wear
yeah on the uh on the podcast and like
that's just
that's just me being me but like you
know hey grill random
tangent who's the worst nickelback or
creed
oh nickelback really yeah i'll go with
creole on that one
you take creed over nickelback yeah i
feel like i always say that though
that's the music
that white women dance to at white strip
clubs in the middle of america oh yeah
they do with all
flat open working a pole to that we're
gonna pull
getting down with the get down